[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياد في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
نبداها من لبنان وهذه الصور من بلده كحاله
في جبل لبنان التي شهدت مقتل شخصين في
اطلاق نار حيث قال حزب الله اللبناني ان
احد عناصره كان مكلفا بحمايه شاحنه قتل
بينما قال حزب القوات اللبنانيه ان مجموعه
مسلحه كانت ترافق الشاحنه اطلقت النار
باتجاه مواطنين من البلده
وهذه هي صور من ساو باولو حيث تقتتم اليوم
في البرازيل قمه لدول حوض الامازون
المنعقده لانشاء تحالف لحمايه بيئه
الامازون وغاباتها
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
عشيه قمه مرتقبه للاكواس مصادر تكشف عن
لقاء قاده الانقلاب في نيامي بمبعوثين
للرئيس النيجيري وللمجموعه قاده الانقلاب
يعلنون حاله التاهب القصوى ويتهمون فرنسا
بخرق مجالهم الجوي واطلاق سراح ارهابيين
باريس سانفي واشنطن تقول انها تدرس
خياراتها للتعامل مع المشهد
بيلاروسيا مساحه تراشق بين موسكو والنيتو
بعد تعزيز بولندا والاتفيا وجودهما
العسكري على الحدود
يتهم الحلف بحشد اكثر من 350 الف عسكري
قرب بيلاروسيا
واشنطن تقول ان لوكاشينكو يمكن الكرملين
عبر وجود عناصر فاينر على ارضه وتعلن
عقوبات على افراد وكيانات في
مع تصاعد حده الاشتباكات في ام درمان
السودان محور سجال في جلسه بمجلس الامن
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده تحذر من استمرار القتال
وتقول انه يزيد من خطر التدخل الاجنبي
وتفتت البلاد المندوب السوداني يتهم قوه
اقليميه بدعم ما سماه العدوان على حكومه
بلاده
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه
وتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وكذلك دوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
من جديد طالب اللجوء ماس على ضفاف المتوسط
[موسيقى]
عشيه قمه الاستثنائيه للاكوكواس بشان
النيجر اكدت المجموعه الافريقيه على
اولويه الدبلوماسيه وان كانت لا تستبعد
التدخل العسكري ياتي ذلك في وقت اعلن فيه
قاده الانقلاب حاله التاهب القصوى بعد
اتهامهم لفرنسا بخرق مجالهم الجوي واطلاق
سراح ارهابيين وهو الامر الذي نفته باريس
في المقابل قالت مصادر نيجيريه لوكاله
رويترز ان قاده الانقلاب التقوا فينيامي
بمبعوثين احدهما للرئيس النيجيري واخر
لرئيس ايكوس
قبيل ساعات على قمه ابو جل الاستثنائيه
لبحث انقلاب النيجر تبدو المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا اكواس امام
امتحان صعب بشان طبيعه الخطوه القادمه
للتعامل مع قاده الانقلاب هناك فرغم
تاكيدها انها مستمره في اتخاذ جميع
التدابير من اجل استعاده النظام الدستوري
في النيجر فان طريق الامثل لتحقيق ذلك لا
يبدو انه محسوم حتى الان قد يكون هناك
تدخل عسكري مباشر حتى لو كان محفوفا
بمخاطر اشعال صراع طويل الامد في منطقه
تخيم عليها الهشاشه الامنيه ام المغامره
بعمليه محدوده خاطفه تنفذها قوات خاصه
تسيطر على المواقع الاستراتيجيه وان كان
نجاحها محل شك فهي ربما تواجه برده فعل
شعبيه غاضبه ام يكتفى بالرهان على خيار
تشديد العقوبات لاعاده الامور في الى ما
قبل السادس والعشرين من يوليو رغم تداعيات
ذلك على مصداقيه ايكواس وحديثها على ان
زمن التعامل مع الانقلابات بوصفها امرا
واقعا قد ولى الى غير رجعه تقول نيجيريا
التي تراس المجموعه الافريقيه حاليا ان
قرارا بالتدخل العسكري لم يتخذ بعد وان
الاولويه تبقى للحل الدبلوماسي وان كانت
الخيارات الاخرى حاضره على طاوله قاده
المجموعه
نيجيريا كانت قد فرضت مزيدا من العقوبات
على جارتها الشماليه شملت افرادا وكيانات
مرتبطه بالمجلس العسكري في النيجر عقب
رفضه السماح بدخول وفد مشترك من مجموعه
ايكواس والاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده
في حين بدا لافته تصعيد قاده الانقلاب ضد
فرنسا واتهام قواتها بارتكاب اعمال عدائيه
خطيره تهدف الى زعزعه امن البلاد اذ اتهم
الناطق باسم ما يطلق على نفسه اسم المجلس
الوطني لح الوطن القوات الفرنسيه بخرق
المجال الجوي للنيجر واطلاق سراح ارهابيين
ما اسفر عن تعرض مواقع للحرس الوطني
لهجمات ارهابيه واضاف المتحدث ان المجلس
قرر وضع القوات المسلحه وقوات الامن في
حاله تاهب القصوى بعد تلك التطورات لكن
باريس التي ينظر اليها بوصفها الخاسر
الغربيه الاكبر من انقلاب النيجر والداعم
الاهم لخيار اعاده بازوم الى السلطه نفت
تلك الاتهامات على ان تطور الداخلي الاهم
داخل المشهد المتشابك في النيجر قد يكون
في اعلان الوزير السابق بيسا اجبولا الذي
كان ايضا قياديا في حركه تمرد مسلحه تاسيس
مجلس المقاومه من اجل الجمهوريه بهدف
العمل على اعاده الرئيس المحتجز محمد
بازوم الى السلطه الامر الذي يعد اول مؤشر
على وجود مقاومه داخليه في النيجر لحكم
المجلس العسكري
هذا وقال البيت الابيض انه ما زال يعتقد
انه يجب حل ازمه النيجر عبر السبل
الدبلوماسيه بينما قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيهوميلر ان واشنطن تدرس
عددا من الخيارات بشان النيجر وهي على
تواصل مع شركائها للوصول الى مسار يؤدي
الى عوده النظام الدستوري واضاف ان واشنطن
قلقه للغايه بشان صحه رئيس النيجر المحتجز
وعائلته
اذهب الينا من نيامي يوسف ساريبا مدير
تحرير صحيفه اصداء النيجر ومن في المانيا
اداما
مدير الاتصال السابق في المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا اكواس اهلا
بكم ابدا بضيف من نيام السيد يوسف
صريبه
عشيه القمه قمه ابوجا لمجموعه ايكواس وما
ينتظر من هذه القمه مصادر من داخل بان
هناك او تم استقبال مبعوث من قبل الرئيس
النيجيري وكذلك من قبل
الاخوه في النيامي ما الذي يعنيه ذلك عشيه
القمه
شكرا جزيلا وفعلا غدا
سوف
تجتمع تعقد قمه قمه استثنائيه
حول الازمه الازمه في النيجر وهذا
الاجتماع ياتي
بعد اجتماع تم عقده يوم الاحد 30 من يوليو
حيث تم الاعلان عن عقوبات ضد النيجر اذا
اليوم
بعد اكثر من اسبوع من تلك العقوبات
ويبدو ان الوضع لم يتطور ولم تحصل النتائج
المرجوه اذا من هنا ياتي هذا الاجتماع
الاستثنائي الذي قد يسمح باحداث تقدم في
الوضع
وكون
كانت ذلك الوفد الذي تم قبوله هذا مؤشر
على ان الامور قد
تتحسن
وتسير في الاتجاه
الصحيح وبالنظر الى
الازمه
كان لها موقف حازم
وحتى خياراته
التي اقترحها
للعسكريين الانقلابيين كانت تتمثل في خيار
واحد وهو طلب
التخلي عن الحكم واعاده الرئيس محمد
بازوم
والوفد الذي كان يقوده
رئيس السابق لنيجيريا لم يتمكن من ان
يتحدث مع
الجنرال عبد الرحمن جامي وذلك الوفد كان
قد جاء
بخيار واحد وهو ان يقول
للعسكريين ينبغي التنحي اذا هذا الاجتماع
هذه هذه نقطه مهمه اسال عنها ضيفي السيد
ادم عن طبيعه ما يكون قد حمله هذا الوفد
من قبل الرئيس النيجيري وكذلك من قبل
ويمكن ان يحدث فرقا فيما قد ينجم عن قمه
الغد سيد اداما
ينبغي القول بان الوفد الذي تم استقباله
من قبل الجنرال عبد الرحمن شاني ليس وفدا
هو مكون من
من الامير لا
لمسي الذي كان طويلا امير منطقه كانو
والذي ايضا كان
محافظا للبنك المركزي لنيجر في نيجيريا
واذا كانوا
يلعبوا دورا تاثيرا وفيه
التاثير الثقافي
اذا هذا يعني ان
الانقلابيين لكن ينبغي ان نعرف شيئا وهو
اذا انه اذا
قام هذا الوفد واستقبال الوفد وذلك
لحفظ ماء الوجه لانه
دخل في عمليه تحد
بالتهديد باستخدام القوه العسكريه معنى
ذلك ان جميع شعوب المنطقه
ستكون معرضه لخطر
هل ترجح ان هذا الوفد قد حمل شيئا جديدا
يفسر استقباله هذه المره بعدما تم رفض في
الايام الماضيه استقبال موفدين من قبل
الرئيس النيجيري وكذلك من قبل هل يحمل
جديدا باعتقادك
الاسياخ تغير قبل اسبوع عندما جاء الجنرال
عبد السلام ابو بكر
والسلطان سكوته محمد سوادي ابو بكر هما
شخصيتان كبيرتان من شمال نيجيريا ذهب الى
النيجر
السياق كان هو ان
تستخدم العضلات وتريد وتهدد باستخدام
القوه العسكريه الان الوضع قد تغير كان
هناك صمود حتى في داخل
نيجيريا ضد التدخل العسكري وكذلك الوضع
الجميع ضد ذلك وكذلك الناس يكتشفون ان
فرنسا هي التي تدير الخيوط وتحرك الدمى
الان نيجيريون
فهموا انه يتعاملون مع شركاء افارقه خاصه
ان طريقه الحوار تم فتحه من خلال تدخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي
تقوله الان اسال ضيفي من نيامي السيد يوسف
ان كانت رشحت اي معلومات او اصداء عما
حمله المفدان الى اليامي وما المنتظر غدا
من قمه ابوجا على الاقل اصداء هذه القمه
نحن نعتقد
ان هذا الوفد الاخير سوف
[موسيقى]
ياتي
باقتراح او باقتراحات جديده
ربما تسمح
بالسير قدما
ونعرف ان العسكريين كانوا صامدين لا
يريدون ترك الحكم واعاده محمد بازوم
يمكن ان نفكر بان هذا الوفد الجديد سياتي
[موسيقى]
قبل هذا الاجتماع هذه القمه كما قلت يحاول
ان يعيد الحوار مع
العسكريين من اجل تغيير موقفه
اقتراحات من قبيل ماذا اقتراحات جديده كما
ذكرت
بان نجزم بذلك لانه ليس هناك معلومات
رسميه تفيد بان هذا هذه المقترحات
وطبيعتها لكن
ربما من هنا الى الغد فالمواقف قد تتغير
من جانب الايكواس وكذلك من جانب مجلس
الحكم العسكري
وهناك ضغوط وهناك ذلك الخيار العسكري
وربما يكون هناك افاق اخرى
قد يتلخص في فرض اجنده على العسكريين
ويمكن
اعاده النظام الدستوري في اجل معقول شكرا
تؤدي الى اطلاق سراح الرئيس شكرا لك من
نيامي يوسف سريبه مدير تحرير صحيفه اصداء
النيجر وكذلك ضيفي من المانيا ادم جاي
مدير الاتصال السابق في المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الدفاع الروسيه ان روسيا ستحشد
قواتها على حدودها الغربيه في ظل تضاعف
وجود النيتو في شرق اوروبا بواقع مرتين
ونصف ياتي ذلك بعد ان اعلنت بولندا
ولاتفيا عن تعزيزات على الحدود مع
بيلاروسيا في ظل ما وصفته بالمخاطر
الامنيه المتزايده وفي ظل هذه التطورات
قالت واشنطن ان وصول عناصر من فاجنر الى
بيلاروسيا مثال اخر على تمكين الرئيس
لوكاشينكو للكرملين ضد مصالح شعبه بينما
اعلن وزير الخارجيه انتوني بلينكن ان
بلاده فرضت عقوبات على افراد وكيانات في
بيلاروسيا
على الجانب الغربي والشمالي الغربي
لاوكرانيا وتحديدا على حدودها مع بولندا
وبيلاروسيا تمت قلق وحشد لقوه اضافيه اشر
اليه وزير الدفاع الروسي سيلقي شويغو
بالقرب من حدود دوله الاتحاد يتمركز تجمع
من القوات يضم حوالي 360 الف عسكري
وثمانيه الاف مصفحه وسته الاف منظومه
مدفعيه وقاذفه الغام عدد افراد تشكيلات
الدول غير الاقليميه في حلف شمال الاطلسي
ارتفع بنسبه اثنين ونصف منذ فبراير من
العام الماضي وتجاوز 30 الف شخص المخاطر
الحاليه ترتبط بعسكره بولندا التي اصبحت
الاداه الرئيسيه لسياسه الولايات المتحده
المناهضه لروسيا
تصريحات تاتي بينما وافقت وزاره الدفاع
البولنديه على ارسال قوات اضافيه الى
الحدود مع بيلاروسيا خطوه تاتي بعد ظهور
مقاتلين لمجموعه فاجنر قرب الحدود وقراته
وارسو اشاره غير مباشره لها وللجناح
الشرقي
وليس بعيدا اعلنت حكومه لطفيه تعزيز
الحدود مع بيلاروسيا بسبب مقاله انها
مخاطر امنيه
ذاك على الحدود لكن على الجبهات تستمر
المعارك هنا دخان انفجار في منطقه
شمال الشرقي مقاطعه موسكو قوته فتحت مجال
تكهنات عن اسبابه خصوصا وان موسكوبات ضمن
بنك اهداف مسيرات اوكرانيه في المده
الاخيره تسارع خدمه الطوارئ الروسيه لتوضح
بانهم انفجار لمستودع للالعاب الناريه
تسبب بدوره في انفجار مصنع لمده تصوير
ومراقبه واجهزه طبيه ومخبريه لكن في مكان
اخر كانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تعلن احباط
محاوله اوكرانيه لتنفيذ هجوم بطائرتين
مسيرتين على العاصمه موسكو وضواحيها
اسقطتهما انظمه الدفاع الجوي الاولى في
منطقه
على الجبهات اكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
مواصلته هجومها على ثلاثه محاور
فيولوجيا وتنفيذ غاره على مواقع للقوه
الروسيه في هذه الجبهات في الايمان
بدنياتك تحدثت الدفاع الروسيه عن صدها
هجمات للجيش الاوكراني كما هجمت بالمروحيه
مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه ومراكز قياده
ومراقبه
قالت القوه الروسيه انها السيطره على
مواقع كانت للقوات الاوكرانيه وتصدت
لهجمات اوكرانيه عده على مواقعه على هذا
المحور محور زابولوجيا بدا ملتهبا في
الايام الاخيره هذه الصور نشرت الدفاع
الروسيه قالت انها لمسيرات روسيه تهاجم
مواقع اوكرانيا واخرى لمدفعيتها وهي
تستهدف تحركا لمجموعات من القوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه رابوتينا
كما نشرت صورا لهجوم بمروحيه عسكريه قلت
انه استهدف مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه
باتجاه ليمان
الروايه الاوكرانيه بالمقابل تحدثت عن
ثلاث جبهات صدت فيها هجمات روسيه في بخموت
ورسخ التقدمها في بعض المحاور
مشهد الحرب المستمره في اوكرانيا
وتداعيتها يتزامنان مع استمرار المساعدات
المقدمه حيث كانت واشنطن قد اعلنت
الموافقه على ارسال الدفعه الاولى من
دبابات ابرامز واحد حيث تم الاعلان عن
ارسال 31 دبابه الى اوكرانيا تصل في مطلع
الخريف المقبل رئيس الاستحواذ في الجيش
الامريكي دوج بوش كان قد ذكر ان هذه
الدبابات سيتم شحنها بكامل معداتها بما
فيها من ذخيره وقطع الغيار ومعدات الوقود
والصيانه وستصل اوروبا اولا ثم بعد ذلك
الى اوكرانيا وتستخدم هل تستخدم هذه
الدبابات مدافع من عيار 120 مليمتر وهي
تختلف عن الاعره تستخدمها الدبابات
الصوفياتيه السابقه في 72
التي كانت اوكرانيا تمتلك عددا منها من
الدوحه معنا العميد الياس حناء الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
اسلحه نوعيه العميد الياس ما الفرق الذي
ستصنعه هذه الاسلحه
عبد القادر اولا نتحدث عن الخريف القادم
يعني المسافه او المده طويله تقريبا يجب
ان تصل هذه الدبابات اولا التدريب عليها
التجهيزات والامر هو ايضا في التعهد يعني
تم الحديث عن الذخيره والتعهد هل ستاتي
هذه الدبابات مع ذخيره من الايراني
والمخضب كما تم الحديث عنه سابقا وهددت
روسيا بمنع هذه الذخيره هذا عامل مهم يجب
ان تصل هذه الدبابات اثنين يجب ان يدرب
عليها يجب ان يتم التدريب والتمرين عليها
وادخالها بالمنظومه يعني هذه الدبابات
تاتي متاخره سته او سبعه اشهر عن الهجوم
الذي تقوده اوكرانيا مع انه متعثر في هذه
الحاله فاذا نحن اما مرحله جديده ولكنها
عمليه استمرار بالنوعيه لهذه الدبابات هل
هذه الدبابات الدفاعات والحمايه الخاصه
فيها هي من المتقدمه يجب ان يعني
نعرف فعلا
القيمه التقنيه لهذه الدبابات ولكنها
بالحد الادنى هي افضل من الدبابات الروسيه
بعده مجالات كان هناك تعاويل على ليبرد في
الايام والشهور الماضيه ولكن حقيقه لم يكن
الطموح كما هي النتائج الان وبالتالي كيف
نقرا المشهد
عبد القادر نتحدث عن جبهه 900 كم
كان الوقت الكافي للقوات الروسيه ان تعد
ما يسمى بالدفاع المرن بعمق 30 كم من
الحفر من
الخنادق المضاده للدبابات من الكثير
الكثير من الالغام وبالتالي هناك قوات
احتياط واستعمال الطيران هذا الامر وضع
عوائق كثيره امام الهجوم الاوكراني خاصه
ان الجيش الاوكراني لا يتمتع بالحمايه
الجويه ولا يتمتع بالحمايه المتنقله يعني
لا لا طوفات لا طائرات وحتى لا دفاعات
جويه تؤمن له هذا التقدم فبدا هذا الامر
صعب عين روسيا الان تتجه غربا وما تقول
بانه حشد من قبل القوات الاطلسي لقوات
هائله والاطلس عينه على بيلاروسيا وعلى
تحديدا ماذا عن هذه المعطيات الجديده
لا تشكل قوه فاجنر هذا التهديد الخطر
ولكنه بضمن المسار للتحضير هي رساله مهمه
370 الف او 360 الف كما قال وزير الدفاع
وهذا امر مبالغ به ولكن اليوم الهاجس
الروسي هو بجبهه بدل ان تكون 100 الف مع
الناتو اصبحت 2500 بعد انضمام فنلندا نحن
في مرحله جديده حتى قائد القوات العسكريه
بالنيتو الامريكي الجنرال كافولي يعد
استراتيجيه جديده الخطوره هي من فاقنر
باماكن التمركز فيها عبد القادر هي تتمركز
على تقاطع
التقاطع الحدود المشتركه بينها ليتوانيا
بيلاروسيا وبولندا وهناك الممر
الاستراتيجي
سوالكي هذا الممر مهم جدا ايضا تتمركز
قوات فاجنر على الحدود المشتركه لتلات دول
بيلاروسيا بولندا اوكرانيا وهناك الممر
اللوجستي لكل الحرب الاوكرانيه
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه العميل
الياس حنا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات في السودان حيث استهدف قصف
الجوي ومدفعي للجيش السوداني مواقع
لقواتها الدعم السريع في شمال الخرطوم
وجنوبها في اثناء ذلك قالت مارتا بوبي
مساعده الامين العام للامم المتحده لشؤون
افريقيا ان استمرار الحرب سيزيد من خطر
التشردم والتدخل الاجنبي وفقدان مستقبل
السودان ودعت خلال جلسه لمجلس الامن طرفي
الصراع للتفاوض لانهاء الحرب باسرع وقت
ممكن اما المندوبه الامريكيه في المجلس
ليندا توماس
فقالت انه ليس من المقبول لاي دوله عضو ان
تمنع مسؤولا بالامم المتحده من تقديم
احاطه لمجلس الامن او ان تهدده
تقدم وتراجع تتقدم المعارك المشهد وتتراجع
فرص التسويه بقلق يراقب السودانيون
مواجهات لا تفتح تتصاعد بين جيشهم وقوات
الدعم السريع
تشتد المعارك على محاور مختلفه لكن
اعنافها يدور في ام درمان احدى مدن
العاصمه الثلاث
وزاره الدفاع السودانيه اكدت مقتل سته من
ضباط جهاز المخابرات بالمدينه
لكن الجيش يتحدث ايضا عن تكبيد قوات الدعم
مئات القتلى والجرحى في معارك ام درمان
فضلا عن تحييد اليات قتاليه والسيطره على
احد مقارما وصفهم بالميليشيا المتمرده
الى جنوب الخرطوم وشمالها يواصل الجيش
تنفيذ قصف جوي ومدفعي متتالي على مواقع
الدعم السريع وكذا بها ترد قوات الدعم
بالمضادات الارضيه
ليس الوضع اقل اضطرابا في دارفور بغربي
البلد يقول الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني ان
الفرقه الحاديه والعشرين في مدينه زالنجي
بوسط الاقليم طردت من سماهم المتمردين من
محيط المدينه
توسعت ساحات الصراع اذا وارتفع التكاليفها
على الصعود كافه فاي حسابات ورهانات تتحكم
في سلوك اطراف الصراع
مجلس الامن الدولي بحث تطورات الاوضاع في
السودان في جلسه دعت اليها بريطانيا واكدت
الولايات المتحده ضروره عقدها كما وجدتها
سانحه لتسجيل هذا الموقف
لا ينبغي لاي بلد اجبار اي شخص على الصمت
ناهيك بشخص يمثل الامم المتحده لقد تلقينا
احاطه ممتازه حقا من مساعد الامين العام
لكنني اعتقد انه ليس من المقبول لاي دوله
عضو ان تمنع مسؤولا اماميا من تقديم احاطه
لمجلس الامن او ان تهدده
الامم المتحده وجدت في الجلسه فرصه لحث
طرفي الصراع على التفاوض لانهاء الحرب
باسرع وقت ممكن
مساعده العميل العام الاموي لشؤون افريقيا
نبهت الى ان استمرار الحرب سيزيد من خطر
التشرذم والتدخل الاجنبي وفقدان مستقبل
السودان والمستقبل تتجاذبه مسارات عده لكن
حتى الان يطغى مسار المواجهه بين طرفين
يستعجل كل منهما الحسم لمصلحته
وبدوره قال المندوب السوداني الحارث ادريس
الحارث ان بلاده لم تهدد رسميا او حتى
خطيا بانهاء عمل البعثه الامميه كما قالت
المندوبه الامريكيه واكد ان الحكومه
السودانيه تدعم عمل البعثه لكنها ترفض
التعامل مع المبعوث الامامي
في الصراع الجاري اتهما مندوب السودان قوه
اقليميه بدعم ما سماه العدوان على حكومه
بلاده لنتابع
هناك من يعتبر ان الصراع هو اشتباك عسكري
بين طرفين لن يؤدي ذلك الى اي حل حكيم
للصراع هذا الصراع هو ترهيب تدعمه قوى
اقليميه وقد ذكرت على وجه الخصوص ان هناك
دوله ارسلت نحو سته الاف مقاتل للقتال ضد
الجيش السوداني واعلنا ايضا من قبل ان هذا
الصراع ليس ثنائيا او بين الطرفين فهو
ينطوي بالفعل على عمليه استبدال ديموغرافي
في السودان يبعد السودانيون قصرا من
منازلهم لتحتلها قوات الدعم السريع
والميليشيات التي تستخدم السودانيين دروعا
بشريه
معنا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني اهلا بك سيد
ضياء كيف وجدت هذه الجلسه مجلس الامن وهذا
السيجاره والطبيع وطبيعه ما اثير فيها
بالنظر لما يجري في الميدان نعم من الواضح
انه هنالك موقف قوي بالنسبه للحكومه
السودانيه في هذه البحصه وهو الرفض ان
يكون فولكر متحدث في هذه الجلسه لان
الحكومه السودانيه اتخذت موقف اتجاه هذا
هذا المبعوث وكذلك هنالك ازدواجيه معايير
اذا نظرنا الى ما حدث في مالي تم طرد
البعثه تمام رغم انها كانت على البنده
السابع ولكن مع ذلك حدثت استجابه ولكن
حينما طالب السودان بان يبعث فولكر لم تتم
الاستجابه له وكان هنالك ضغط من غير
الولايات المتحده يعني يشارك فورتر في هذه
الجلسه ولكن الموقف الدبلوماسيه السودانيه
كان قوي جدا رفضوا وقالوا بانه سيتخذ
سينسحب من هذه الجلسه
وسيرتب الاوضاع مع المركز مع الخرطوم فيما
يتعلق بمستقبل البحث طيب وماذا عن الاشاره
حسب مندوب السودان الى دوله اقليميه
بموصفها بانها تساهم ولها يد فيما وصفه
بالعدوان على بلاده واضح ان هنالك تدخلات
مختلفه اذا كانت تدخلات اقليميه قريبه او
التدخلات بعيده بعض الشيء هذه الحرب التي
تتم الان في السودان هنالك اطراف اقليميه
تدخلت فيها خاصه
في الفتره الاخيره خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالاعداد الكبيره من الجنود من النيجر
جاؤوا الى السودان وشاركوا في هذه
المعارك وذلك ظهرت خلال التجاذبات ما بين
المجموعه المنقلبه الان والرئيس السابق
وواضح كذلك ان هنالك اطراف في مناطق
مختلفه في افريقيا هذه القوات قوات الدعم
السريع قوات عابره للحدود تتشكل وفق اسس
قبليه وعرقيه تمتد في غرب افريقيا في
مناطق ودول عديده فبالتالي هذا محطه كذلك
الامكانيات التي ظهر بها الدعم السريع
الامكانيات القتاليه وضحت بان هنالك الدعم
كبير يقدم الى الى هذا الفصيل وهو لا
يتحرك بامكانياته الذاتيه لان امكانياته
الذاتيه لا توفر له هذا هذا هذه
الامكانيات الكبيره الامكانيات العسكريه
والامكانيات وغير ذلك سجال الحاد في مجلس
الامن وايضا اشتباكات حاده في اليومين
الماضيين خاصه ما جرى في ام درمان وتباين
البيانات من الطرفين عما حقق نتائج في هذه
الاشتباكات الحاده
امن الصعوبه للوصول الى حقائق حاسمه
ونهايه فيما يتعلق بهذه الصراعات صحيح
تتداخل الدعايه السياسيه من كل طرف يقول
بانه انتصر ولكن المعطيات الاساسيه تقول
بان هنالك التقدم واضح للجيش للجيش في
الفترات السابقه كان
موجود في مقره يدافع عن مقاري كان في حاله
في حاله دفاعيه كامله ولكنه الان انتقل
الى مرحله الهجوم عبر طرق مختلفه عبر
الاعمار الخاصه عبر الاشاره الارضي
الواسعه على سته محاور كما حدث امس وهنالك
التحرك على سته محاور وهذا هو التحرك
الاكبر والاشمل بالنسبه للجيش السوداني
وهذا يوضح طبيعه الصراع ومالات توازن
القوى الان بانه يمضي الى صالح الجيش
ولكنه لا نقول بانه ذلك يعني بان الجيش قد
اقترب من تحقيق النصر نهائي لان هذه الحرب
معقده هذه الحرب تتم وتدور
بالقرب منازل المواطنين وبقرب من الاعيان
المدنيه للمستشفيات وغير ذلك فهنالك كثير
من التعقيدات التي تصعب على الجيش بان
ينجز هذه المهمه
دون ان تكون هنالك خسائر خسائر داخل الجيش
وخساير في المحيط المدني الذي يتاثر بهذا
الصراع لوجود الدعم السريع في هذه المساحه
السكانيه التي بها اعداد كبيره من
المواطنين والسوداني بلال الكاتب المحلل
السياسي السوداني شكرا جزيلا
استمرار المواجهات المسلحه في السودان بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع فاقم من الاوضاع
المعيشيه للسكان ومن بين المتاثرين موظفوا
القطاع العام الذين لم يحصلوا على رواتبهم
منذ نحو اربعه اشهر يخشى كثيرون ان يؤدي
استمرار توقف صرف الرواتب الى عدم قدره
الموظفين على تامين متطلبات اسرهم
المعيشيه
منذ اكثر من عشرين عاما تعمل بتول موظفه
في احدى المؤسسات الصحيه بولايه الجزيره
وسط السودان تواصل عملها وتنهمك في
تفاصيله رغم عدم تلقيها لراتبها منذ اربعه
اشهر
[موسيقى]
لكن اعباء المنزل ومصاريفه ليست وحدها ما
ينتظر بتول ويثقل كاهلها
الاربع شهور دي صعب علينا شديد من ناحيه
مواصلات من ناحيه اكل من ناحيه علاج انا
بتلك كبيره بتاخد انسولين يعني الانسولين
ده بقينا مشان شنو نحضر لها جرعه الشهر
ليست بتول فحسب لكن مئات الاف الموظفين في
القطاعين الحكومي والخاص يواجهون صعوبات
كبيره في تدبر شعور حياتهم
غير ان من شردتهم الحرب تبدو معاناتهم
مضاعفه واقع لم يسلم من تداعياته ادم الذي
اجبرته الحرب على ترك منزله مع اسرته
والتوجه الى احد مراكز الايواء
اننا ايجارات في
ظهرنا احنا خلينا بيوتنا والتغذيه الابناء
يعني عندهم قزازه معين بياخذوه واللبن
الحليب اليوماتي
وحاجات كثيره يعني فقدناها في
الاستحقاقات او الرواتب
اخرون اضطروا الى ترك وظائفهم والبحث عن
مصدر اخر للرزق لتامين حاجات اسرهم انا
شخصيا على المستوى الشخصي اجرتلي محل
عدم صرف رواتب الموظفين لعده اشهر القى
بظلاله على قطاعات واسعه من السودانيين بل
وادخل بعضهم في دائره الفقر المتقع
تركت الحرب اثارها على العاملين في مختلف
القطاعات في السودان بين عاطل عن العمل او
فاقد لمصدر رزقه اضافه الى معاناه موظفي
الدوله معاناه يتوقع لها ان تتفاقم كل ما
طال امد الحرب في البلاد
اسامه سيد احمد الجزيره من مدينه ودمدن
بولايه الجزيره وسط السودان
[موسيقى]
التقى وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن نظيره هو الجزائري احمد عطاف في
واشنطن وبحث العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين وقلب لينك خلال اللقاء ان شراكه
مع الجزائر تنمو بشكل اقوى ولد البلدين
روابط امنيه واقتصاديه مهمه مؤكدا على
اهميه تعزيز الشراكه بين البلدين بشكل
اكبر في العديد من المجالات بما فيها
مكافحه الارهاب وتعزيز السلام في منطقه
الساحل من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه
الجزائري احمد عطاف ان العلاقات بين
البلدين قطعت اشواطا طويله من الود او
عفوا من الوفاء بالوعود مشيرا الى ان
العلاقات الاقتصاديه تتزايد وتتنوع
في لبنان افاد مراسل الجزيره بمقتل شخصين
احدهما من عناصر حزب الله في اطلاق نار
ببلده الكحاله في جبل لبنان ونقل مراسل
الجزيره عن مصدر امني اللبناني قوله ان
مسلحين اطلق او مسلحين اطلق النار باتجاه
شبان تجمعوا امام شاحنه كانت قد انقلبت
على الطريق الرئيسي في منطقه الكحاله وقال
حزب الله في بيان ان مسلحين اطلقوا النار
باتجاه شاحنه للحزب انقلبت في الكحاله ما
اسفر عن مقتل احد المكلفين بحمايتها اما
حزب القوات اللبنانيه فقالت ان مجموعه
مسلحه كانت ترافق شاحنه يعتقد انها تحمل
سلاحا اطلقت النار باتجاه مواطنين من
الكحاله فيما طالب رئيس الحكومه اللبنانيه
نجيب بيقاتي الذي تابع التطورات مع قائد
الجيش بكشف ملابسات الحادث ودعا الى
الهدوء وانتظار نتائج التحقيق في الحادث
معنى منا بيروت مراسل الجزيره ايهاب
العقده الالهاب ايهاب ما الذي جرى وكيف هو
الوضع العام
شاحنه تابعه لحزب الله اصطدمت هنا خلفي
تماما عند هذا الحائط الاسمنتي في الطريق
الذي يربط منطقه البقاع اللبناني بالعاصمه
بيروت وبضحيتها الجنوبيه والشرقيه عند
بلده الكحال الشاحنه التي ترونها الان في
الصوره هي الشاحنه البيضاء اللون كانت
تحمل
اسلحه كما قال اهالي بلده الكحال ولكن ذلك
لم يصدر عنه اي توضيح من الجيش اللبناني
الذي نقل الصناديق الخشبيه باتجاه مراكزه
بعنايه فائقه وبمواكبه عسكريه كبيره حزب
الله كان جلب هذه الرافعه لنقل الصناديق
الخشبيه الى شاحنه اخرى الروايه اهالي
بلده الكحال تتحدث عن ان عناصر حزب الله
اطلقوا النيران باتجاه الشبان الذين
حاولوا مساعده السائق فاذا كانوا لا
يعرفون
ماذا تحمل هذه الشاحنه مما ادى الى مقتل
احد الشبان روايه حزب الله كانت تتحدث
ايضا عن ان الشبان اطلقوا النيران باتجاه
عناصر حزب الله الذين ردوا بالمثل وادى
ذلك الى اشتباك بين الطرفين الجيش
اللبناني استخدم قوه كبيره الى المكان
وعملت الى تطويق كل هذه المنطقه نشاهد
ايضا خلفي السكان امام كنيسه البلده الذين
تجمهروا اعتراضا على ما جرى يقولون انهم
مستمرون في
اقفال الطريق الدولي الذي يربط البقاع
اللبناني
بالعاصمه بيروت وبضحيتها الجنوبيه كانت
القوات اللبنانيه اصدرت بيانا دعت فيه
الجيش اللبناني الى اتخاذ التدابير
اللازمه واجراء التحقيقات بشان ما حصل
لكشف ملابساتها واستغربت اطلاق النار
باتجاه المدنيين
الذين كانوا في هذه البلده هذه هي عمليا
المعطيات على الارض بانتظار معلومات
اضافيه من الجهات الامنيه التي ربما تكشف
المزيد من التفاصيل عن التحقيقات التي
كانت بداتها في هذه المنطقه الجيش ايضا
استخدم اليات اضافيه لرفع الشاحنه وعمد
الاهالي منذ بعض الوقت الى اغلاق الطريق
امامه باعتبار ان هذه الشاحنات يقولون
انها يجب ان لا تخرج من المكان ويجب ان
تبقى هنا بانتظار كشف ملابسات التحقيقات
التي يجريها الجيش اللبناني
من يقولون انه مستمرون في اعتصامهم
شكرا لك من بلده الكحاله بجبل لبنان مراسل
الجزيره ايهاب العقده العقده شكرا جزيلا
لك
[موسيقى]
لقي 41 شخصا على الاقل مصرعهم اثراء غرق
سفيده للمهاجرين قباله جزيره
ايطاليا وقالت وكاله الانباء الايطاليه ان
اربعه نجوا منها الحادث ابلغوا رجال
الانقاذ انهم كانوا على متنقارب انطلق من
صفاقس في تونس وغرق بينما كان في طريقه
الى الشواطئ الايطاليه
كارثه اخرى لطالبي اللجوء وقعت على الحدود
الليبيه التونسيه حيث اكد حرس الحدود
التابع لحكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
للجزيره ان 27 طالب لجوء من دول جنوب
الصحراء بينهم نساء واطفال توفوا خلال
الايام الماضيه بسبب الجوع والعطش وقال
انه عثر على جثث الضحايا ملقاه في الصحراء
بين ليبيا وتونس مشيرا الى ان دورياته
تعثر يوميا على لاجئين تائهين في الصحراء
وتنقلهم الى مراكز مؤقته في منطقه العسا
قرب الحدود مع تونس
مسارات الهجره المحفوفه بالمخاطر عبر
المتوسط نتعرف عليها في هذا العرض
انه البحر الابيض المتوسط او الممر المائي
الذي لا محيد لالاف طالبي اللجوء عن عبوره
خلال بحثهم عن حياه افضل البحر الذي يجمع
بين ثلاث قارات يشهد تدفق طالبي اللجوء من
ثلاثه مسارات شهيره ايضا ليصلوا الى بر
اوروبا المسار الشرقي كان اهمها منذ سنه
2014 عندما بدا الملايين من طالبي اللجوء
الفارين من تدعيه الحروب والصعوبات
الاقتصاديه بغرب اسيا باتخاذ طريق الهجره
الى اليونان وقبرصا وبلغاريا عن طريق
تركيا في المقام الاول اغلبهم من سوريا
والعراق واللبنان وافغانستان ويعد المسار
الغربي اهم طريق يسلكه طالب واللجوء
للوصول الى اسبانيا خصوصا وحتى عام 2018
كان هذا الممر هو الاكثر شيوعا للتقدم نحو
اوروبا الا ان السياسات التي تضعها الدول
لمكافحه الهجره اسهمت في تغيير المهاجرين
لمساراتهم مع مرور الوقت
اما عن اكثر ممر هجره ازدحاما في البحر
الابيض المتوسط فهو الطريق المركزي من
شمال افريقيا نحو اوروبا ويشهد هذا المسار
ازمه انسانيه كبيره اذ وثقت منظمه الهجره
التابعه للامم المتحده وفات اكثر من الف
طالب لجوء على طول الطريق البحري بين شمال
افريقيا والشواطئ الجنوبيه لاوروبا خلال
العام الجاري اضافه الى اكثر من 1800
مفقود في ظل هذا الوضع توصف سياسات مكافحه
الهجره بالصارمه وتضعها الدول وخاصه
للاتحاد الاوروبي لاحتواء ازمه طالبي
اللجوء فقد فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي اجراءات
جديده ضمن اتفاق في يويو الماضي وصف
بالتاريخ ويلزم الاتفاق الدول الاعضاء
بانشاء مراكز على الحدود الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي لاواء الطالبي اللجوء الذين
لديهم فرصه ضئيله احصائيا للحصول على
اللجوء والهدف هو عدم دخولهم اراضي
الاتحاد الاوروبي على ان تخضع طلبات
لجوءهم لف حص سريع من اجل تسهيل عودتهم
الى بلدهم الاصلي او بلد العبور ولا يكاد
المهاجرون يصلون الى حياه افضل بعيدا عن
بلدانهم اذ يموت منهم الكثير في عرض
المتوسط وتقول منظمه الهجره التابعه للامم
المتحده ان ذلك يعود الى تاخر الدول في
بدء عمليه الانقاذ اضافه الى الغياب التام
للاستجابه في بعض حالات طلب المساعده
[موسيقى]
تفاعل مستمر يشهده اعلان وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليتش تجميد المخصصات الماليه
للبلات العربيه داخل الخط الاخضر القرار
يقضي بتجميد تحويل 55 او 55 مليون دولار
كانت مخصصه للتنميه في هذه البلدات البالغ
عددها
قريه وبلده منها 69 عباره عن مجالس محليه
و13 تحمل صفه مجلس مدينه يعيش فيها نحو
49% من فلسطينيين الداخل بينما يعيش نحو
30% في المدن الحكومه الاسرائيليه السابقه
كانت قد صدقت على تلك الميزانيه لتطوير
البنيه التحتيه في البلدات العربيه بحسب
ما نص عليه القرار السابق وهذه هي المره
الاولى التي تقوم فيها اسرائيل بمنع
ميزانيه بلد بلدات محدده على اساس عرقي
وديني تستهدف الفلسطينيين في الداخل في
المقابل فان تقارير اسرائيليه قالت ان
قراره مودريتش ينطوي على اقتطاع 130 مليون
شيكل من هذه المخصصات من اجل تمويل طلاب
المعاهد الدينيه التي تطالب بها الاحزاب
الدينيه في حكومه بنيامين
اذن وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
حجب هذه
الميزانيات في الاولويات بانه سيعيد النظر
في الاولويات الماليه واليات الاشراف
المعمول بها في تلك المناطق قرار ليس
غريبا على سلوكه السياسي ولا على مواقفه
السابقه المعلنه تجاه الفلسطينيين فقد
اعلن سابقا ان لا وجود للشعب الفلسطيني
وانه مجرد اختراع تم خلال القرن الماضي
كما تسبب هذا الوزير مودريتش في
دوليا واسع بعد دعوته لمحو قريه حواره
الفلسطينيه من الوجود بحجه ان سكانها
يحرضون على العداء والعنف والعداء عن هذا
القرار قرار وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
استضيف من بلده عرعر السيد مضر يونس رئيس
اللجنه القطريه لرؤساء السلطات المحليه
العربيه داخل الخط الاخضر سيد مضر وان كان
مسار معروف ولكن ما وجه القانون فيما
اتخذه بهذه الخطوه
هل نعتقد انه هذا قرار غير قانوني ولكن لا
يمكن ان نعتمد اليوم على التوجه القانوني
او التوجه للقضاء الاسرائيلي في هذا الشيء
حتى لو كان الامر
ممكن او هناك الامكانيات بنجاح هذه القضيه
كبيره لانه نحن نتعامل مع عامل الوقت توجه
للمحكمه العليا ياخذ وقت اشهر واكثر وهذه
ميزانياتها تعتمد عليها السلطات المحليه
حاليا وهي بحاجتها على الفار عدم وجود او
تحويل هذه الميزانيات سيؤدي الى انهيار
هذه السلطات المحليه وهذا ما يريده اي بما
معناه ان يضعف القياده الداخليه في داخل
البلدان ان يشتت هذا المجتمع وهذا الشعب
يريدون فراده وتصرفاتنا على شكل فردي
فموقفه من هذه الناحيه هو تعليل وكل مره
بشيء جديد الغايه منه هو هو اضعاف هذا
المجتمع العربي وكما قلتم هو لا يريدون ان
نكون هنا ويحاول بكل طريقه ان يمحي هذا
الوجود
بوضر بان مودريتش ينوي تحويل هذه الاموال
حسب بعض الاخبار الى المعاهد اليمنيه
الدينيه هل هناك ما يؤكد ذلك
بالعكس يعني هو حاول لو رشح هذا الموضوع
من منطلق ان يخلق هناك نوع من الفتنه او
الانشقاق في داخل هذه المجتمعات يعني بغض
النظر نحن لا نلتقي مع المجتمع الديني
بكثير الامور ولكن نلتقي للاسف الشديد في
موقع هو الضعف المادي والوضع الاقتصادي
لهذه
المواقف الاحزاب الدينيه انها ترفض هذا
الشيء ووقفت وقالت لن نقبل ان ياتي هذه
الموارد من منطلق ان تؤخذ من المجتمع
العربي وهذا موقف يعني يحسب لهم بشكل جيد
هذه محاولات اسمه البدايه كانت ان هناك لا
توجد ميزانيه للدوله التي قررت فقط في
نهايه شهر
خمسه هذه السنه فقال لم نحول ميزانيات
بسبب هذا الشيء ثم كان موضوع تحويل 130
مليون شيكل في الموضوع المعاهد الدينيه
والغي وجاءت مطرج بعدها بالادعاء ان هذه
الموارد الماديه في خطر ان تحول لعصابات
الاجرام ونحن مجتمع للاسف الشديد المجتمع
الفلسطيني بالداخل يعاني من افه الاجرام
التي اوجدتها هذه الدوله بسيارتها
التحريضيه والدخول
او دخولها الى خطوره تمرير هذا القرار
خاصه عليكم انتم البلدات العربيه
يعني نتحدث عن الميزانيه
التي تتعلق بالخدمات الاساسيه في داخل
بلدان نتحدث عن دفع معاشات للموظفين نتحدث
عن تعطيل برامج اننا نستطيع ان نقوم فيها
برامج تتعلق الاجتماعي تتعلق في المعيشه
تتعلق في التعليق هناك خطر عن لن نستطيع
ان نفتتح المدارس لا نستطيع ان نرمم هذه
المدارس لا نستطيع ان نؤمن الحراسه لهذه
المدارس فالموضوع هو يتحدث عن اليوم يوم
الخدمات اليوميه لمن نفايات وما شابه كل
هذا الامور السلطات المحلي
اعطيت هناك تعليمات في خلال شهر ثلاثه ان
تشمل من ضمن ميزانيتها السنويه لسنه 2023
هذه المبالغ واليوم بقرار مطرش ويرجعنا
ويؤدي بهذا القرار الى وجود عجز تام في كل
يعني عجز في كل سلطه محليه ولا نتحدث عن
67 يريد ان يدخلها الى عجز وبالتالي
لانهيارها وبالتالي لاخراج القياده العربي
من هذه السلطه وايتاء
ما يسمى باللجان المعينه هذه اجنده ما
يريده
العرب بل يعلوه العرب بطريقه اخرى لا
يريدهم هنا في
هذه طيب هذا القرار سابقا وبالتالي هل
لديكم تصور كيف ستتعاملون مع هذا القرار
بكل شتى الوسائل بطبيعه الحال نحن توجهنا
اولا
هناك مسؤوليه لرئيس الحكومه رئيس الحكومه
نتنياهو هو من بدا بهذه الميزانيات
للتوضيح هذه الميزانيات تعطى ميزانيات
الموازنه تعقل للسلطانه المحليات الضعيفه
من اجل ان توازن ميزانياتها لان المدخولات
لهذه السلطات هي قليله باعتبار المصروفات
وهذا ايضا جاء عن الطريق تمييز اتجاه
السلطات المحلي العربيه ان لم يدخل اليها
هناك
المحل التجاريه وما شابه التي تضر عليها
الموارد الداخليه بهذه الحاله او بهذه
الحاله وبهذا المنطق هي لا تحتاج الدوله
فهما ارغب هذه السلطات المحليه ان تقوم
بحاجه لهبات الموازنه من الدوله توزيع هذه
الهيبات موازنه كان مجحف اي للسلطات
المحليه اليهوديه اكثر من العربيه نحن
حاربنا هذا الشيء في السابق ولذلك اوجدوا
ما معناه الباك موازنه الاضافيه هذه
الهبات الموازنه ليس كما يدعي من ضمن
اتفاقيات ائتلافيه
هي بدات في حكومتنا ثانيه هون الاولى
استمرت في الحكومه السابقه وصدقت في هذه
فبالتالي اولا عالم ثانيا يتخذ الموقف
راينا له موقف واتخذه في شهر سبعه ان تعطى
هذه الميزانيه ولكن مطرش يتصرف بشكل فردي
وكانه لا توجد حكومه لا يوجد رئيس حكومه
كان هناك مركز الحكم المحلي الشامل يضم كل
السلطات المحليه العربيه واليهوديه له
الموقف معانا في هذا الشيء طبعا ممكن توجه
للقضاء وهناك المسار الجماهير الذي نقوم
فيه نحن نتحدث عن قيمه اعتصام قائمه اليوم
للجنه القطريه هناك رؤساء السلطات المحليه
ستكون هناك في وقفه امام
مكتب شكرا يوم الاحد
وسيكون هناك طبعا ممكن الاضراب العام وعدم
افتت
احه من بلده عرعره مضر يونس رئيس اللجنه
القطريه لرؤساء السلطات المحليه العربيه
داخل الخط الاخضر
ختام الحصاد هذه الليله تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]